okay so after the long extended warmup
overview we wanted to dig in in the next
to a talks on onto topic so one is today
to more evolution and then tomorrow
morning Nico will will do tumor
progression models so do revolution
remind you up to the short break right
the cancer is this evolutionary process
accumulation of mutations in a
population of cells some somatic
mutations and so now we want to quantify
this this process so of course as an
evolutionary process there's their
selection happening so so cells that
that acquire a mutation that gives them
a selective advantage will will you know
undergo some will expand in the
population so that you get these
subsequent waves of clonal expansion
this is that the clonal theory of cancer
so now what we'd like to quantify this
well why I mean one because of course
it's it's it's it's interesting to try
to understand it for four basic cancer
biology a basic cancer biology
understand this process but actually
understanding this process and
understanding something bout the order
of mutations is also being recognized
and being important clinically so this
is just one example from from a recent
publication of comparing patients with
it with a certain type of leukemia and
looking at the order of two cancer
causing mutations and what was sort of
observed was that one order of these two
mutations in these two genes if you got
this this mutation this Jack to gene
first that led to worse prognosis for
the patients than if you got the
mutation intet to first so there's
there's inevitably probably more of
these things to come out as we're able
to quantify this this progression
process this evolutionary process
further also
it brought was like what treatment was
affected by the other occupations this
would be the interesting thing right to
show that you can predict it and then
you can tailor the treatment based on it
right so in this publication there was
some hints that these patients responded
differently to to a drug treatment but I
don't recall the details but yeah that
that of course would be even more
important clinically so population of
cells we want to we want to quantify
this process how how do we quantify
evolutionary processes we we we try to
write them down in terms of trees right
so if we've measured a tumor and we've
sequenced this tumor we sequence the
cells in the tumor for now let's assume
we measured every cell then we can
describe the process of mutations
accumulates population via the tree here
a cell tree and so what we'd like to do
then is from the data at the present
time from from the cells and their
mutations try to reconstruct a tree that
describes this this ancestral
relationship so for this this talk we're
going to describe ways to build trees or
to quantify this evolutionary process
using to two different types of models
one or phylogenetic tree models and then
secondly models that deal more with the
population dynamics so there'll be these
two parts okay so first basic
phylogenetic trees i mean this is this
is a huge topic we're not going to give
an intro can't do justice to giving an
intro to reconstructing phylogenetic
trees and data in the context of this
talk but you know again we measure we
have a way of a tree we measure the
leaves of this tree we're going to make
this more precise in another in another
slide and we'd like to reconstruct a
tree that describes these relationship
so you know of course this is done in
many different ways huge literature and
how to reconstruct trees describing the
relationships between species between
all sorts of things you need you need a
a model to do this there's different
approaches approaches based on a
distance
distances if I have only distances
between these species I can try to fit
those distances between a tree between
trees of course in the era of genome
data as it's already sort of a described
this morning Lee or sort of a Lou to the
fact that now with genome data we really
can use these sort of character based
methods so at a high level we can think
of each each cell exhibit encountered we
can we can measure these could be
individual positions of the genome and
we've measured whether there's an AC
tage or at that position so these could
be our characters they could be
something more abstract it could be
whether or not there was a somatic
mutation at the position they could be
whether there's a copy number
aberrations it could be all all sorts of
things but we've measured this these
character for each cell we've measured
some number of characters those
characters have a certain states so here
you know these states for the characters
and what we want to reconstruct them is
a tree that describes the relationship
between these cells again the cells are
the leaves and in our case to make us a
little more precise will will be
interested in finding rooted trees
because in the context of somatic
evolution in cancer we we in fact know
the route the route is the germline
genome so there is always a rooted tree
that we can we think of we're interested
in a binary tree because if we're
modeling the process of individual cells
cells divided into two daughter cells
right at three or four or five so if we
had a cellular resolution and we could
reconstruct everything we'd have this
rooted binary tree now of course all the
difficulty comes in you know what what
model do you use to describe how
characters change over time and then
based on that model you then have to try
to find the tree that maximizes some
objective function for that model right
so we could for example count changes in
characters and then try to you know find
the fewest number of changes that
describe the species we could have a
probabilistic model that describes the
probability of a character changing to
another character and then try to find a
right break down a likelihood for each
tree and then try to find a maximum
likelihood tree both of these problems
in any reasonable
ruction are challenging problems they're
there they're MP they're np-hard
problems but there's all sorts of great
algorithms and approaches that that one
can use so let's formulate a simple
model to make this this a little more
concrete for somatic mutations we'll
we'll start by assuming all somatic
mutations are single nucleotide variants
if we had about copy number aberrations
and structural rearrangements and all
this crazy stuff just assume that the
only somatic mutations are single letter
changes in the sequence secondly we're
going to make another assumption the
so-called infinite sites assumption
which is to say that a mutation occurs
at a position only once during the
evolutionary process so this assumption
is one that you know for tumors is if
we're thinking about single nucleotide
mutations it's a simplifying assumption
may be somewhat reasonable you know we
expect that the genome is pretty long
the chance that you know randomly a
mutation would happen in the exact same
nucleotide is pretty low so let's assume
that that probability is a zero we have
the the so-called infinite sites
assumption so when then according to
that assumption then every every
character single nucleotide variant is
our character if a mutation only happens
once in a position it means that we can
just measure that position as a binary
character every position in the genome
is either mutated or not and so we build
this binary character matrix describing
our our measurement ourselves now i
should say i think was on the slide and
i forgot to say it that the other
assumption that is made in character
based phylogeny is that the the
characters are evolving independently
all right so we've taken independent
character for single nucleotide variants
of course independent positions this
assumption will will will break down so
now given this video will break down to
a more complicated rearrangements given
us matrix we'd like to reconstruct the
phylogenetic tree it's a very simple
model the so called a rooted binary
perfect phylogeny model okay so let's
get describe the trees that exhibit this
model rooted trees the root is the
normal or unmutated state again this is
our
assumption because we're evolving from
the germline genome the leaves are the
cells that we we measure each node it is
is labeled by this binary string
indicating which mutations are present
at that node so here's the one we
measured that the ones we've measured at
the leaves is as well as potentially
some other since a mutation happens only
once every mutation labels only one edge
on the tree and the edge labels on the
unique path to the root actually spell
out the mutations that are present in
that cell okay very straightforward
model turns out in this is a so-called
perfect phylogeny theorem here the
references to Dan Gus fields work
although I guess it's also in the book
so I should you should buy the book and
read more about perfect for lodging this
is in a sense the simplest possible
version it's the rooted version binary
characters we have the ancestor we know
the ancestor it's the all 0 state ok so
then there's a nice characterization
first telling us if I give you such a
binary matrix does it exhibit this this
rooted binary perfect phylogeny and in
fact all you need to do is is check
pairs of columns and see that that no
pair of columns contains all three of
the poss of the state 0 1 1 0 1 1 so
called three gametes condition here some
of you may know the four Gammy's
condition when you have the when you
don't have the all 0 root yeah question
branch um multum oh we don't we don't
know we don't we don't need multiple
mutations on a branch necessarily hmmm
yeah these colored dots here are the
mutations I don't necessarily have
multiple mutations on a branch I just
have well I mean essentially on some
branches I don't even have any mutations
so that's why I've kind of dropped them
and down here right so so so so this one
yes this is where there were sort of 22
mutations on this branch but that's the
district really would we were resolve
and I guess you know we would resolve it
this way because we really you know
start with we measure the the leaves
here and then we're trying to sort of
build the tree that fits this data under
the assumption where there's at most one
mutation so I could actually have put in
a note here that had an edge with just
the red dot than in a node and then an
edge with just the green dot it would be
this chain and but I could delete that
node because there's doesn't need to be
there
simplest possible model you can
reconstruct the tree in time linear in
the matrix right so great everything
works the model of course is is is is
very simple but yeah ah it's it's unique
it's it's unique under let's see if I'll
get this right and then dang can correct
me if that the columns if there are no
repeated columns I think you'll get
uniqueness yeah in this in this simple
one yeah solve this one Ellen's in this
in my cartoon this one's a non-binary
enforcement I said every one of our guys
assumption is for partners uh sorry
binaries not binary tree here it's
binary bits are if binary character it's
to state character probably have been
better if I said to state character not
binary tree 01 characters that's yeah
and
okay so I mean that was really simple so
what happens in tumor phylogeny what are
the complications why is why is there
anything to do that's different from all
the other work that's been done in
phylogeny you for the past several
decades yeah Christian so if there is
that one edge at the very top which all
of them share that mutations dosimeter
yeah yeah right well we'd see these
mutations remember these are we're
detecting somatic mutations so we'll
assume that this process that we
discussed in the previous lecture of
detecting somatic mutations has worked
and the way we knew they were there is
we compared to the germline genome these
are interesting mutations these are
mutations that one could think are you
know the early ones you know before some
of these later clonal expansions right
not all of these are interesting in fact
a bunch of these mutations are in every
single tumor cell they're probably just
passenger a bunch of them are presumably
passenger mutations that accumulated in
that first founder sell the tumor before
it even became cancerous right so any
random mutation in that you know
cellular lineage would be there as well
so there tend to actually be a fair
number of mutations up here
and sometimes the easiest to detect
because they're in every cell in the
tumor so once down here that are hard
okay so what what makes the problem
harder in cancer some due to the
challenges in the measurement so we
generally for a lot of the data as I'll
show you we don't measure single cells
we measure mixture of left cells when we
do measure single cells or even
sometimes of a measure mixture we have
observation errors we have measurement
errors and we need to deal with those a
lot of phylogeny models have been around
don't really deal with measurement error
and then we have these issues with these
complex aberrations and so if we want to
understand how those progressed in our
population then we start to run into
problems with some of the assumptions
that that that are used so let's let me
talk about the first challenge in the
Mogo will go through the other two so
this this question of sequencing
mixtures ok so again a lot of the data
if we don't do single cell sequencing if
we in fact just sequence this whole
tumor sample now we don't have every
single cell measured we've got all them
all mixed together so now in terms of
this tree I haven't measured the leaves
of the tree individually instead I've
given you all the leaves simultaneously
and now can you do anything there seems
actually hard to do anything so what's
what's also been done recently
especially as sequencing costs have
gotten lower and as you need less
material to sequence you could chop up
your tumor into multiple pieces sequence
multiple samples from the same tumor and
then try to reconstruct a tree there's
some of the published trees you'll see
from from from experiments like this
actually what they're they're doing is
reconstructing a trade treating each of
these mixtures as actually the same
thing so if we think about it in terms
of this say binary matrix where we
originally had a matrix on cells and
mutations really what these are each
each sample is a mixture of these so
somehow this is a collapsed matrix and
so we can look at this collapse matrix
and try to use existing phylogenetic
trees techniques to relate samples but
then we're not address
saying the fact that somehow each of
these was a mixture we're losing
information ok so we presumably would
want to try to recover this information
yeah can you explain how these mixtures
that arrived so how do we observe 11110
x.x how do we get the excellence yes ok
so let's let's say that that the this
this one sample had really to two
different cell types right and what
we're measuring are the superposition of
those two cells so just it's just the
it's just before it's just beat yeah
it's just the order of the rows right
assuming I've yeah it's just the or the
rose so it's the superposition ok so we
can of course take this this data which
is lost information and you plug it into
an existing technique but could we do
more and this is I think we're you know
a cancer evolution tomb revolution
starts to differ a little bit from some
of the techniques that have been used so
we could start to try to recover some of
this information for example if we take
that same perfect phylogeny model and
assume that we only looked at single
nucleotide mirrors very amused the
perfect for lodging assumption we could
try to say could we resolve a perfect
phylogeny from the superposition of
these rows and there's been work done in
this area i'm not going to go into the
details but it's sort of a combinatorial
model that tries to find somehow the
minimal perfect phylogeny matrix that
explains this data as superpositions of
the rose
there's there's a there's a heuristic it
turns out to be an np-hard problem as
was claimed in one publication and the
proof was was in a subsequent
publication correctly but there's an ILP
we can do with ILP yeah but even doing
that we're losing information because if
you recall in the previous lecture we're
talking about detecting single
nucleotide mutations we had these these
reads that were telling us whether or
not that the mutation was there but more
importantly we can look at the reads
that are telling us whether the mutation
is there and actually count up how many
reads have the somatic mutation and this
is the so-called variant allele
frequency so if i look at the fraction
of reads covering a position that
contained the variant allele meaning the
somatic mutation then this variant
allele frequency should be proportional
to the fraction of cells that had that
mutation again assuming no copy number
aberrations right so if every cell in
that in the sample had the mutation and
it was a homozygous mutation even then
the very low frequency is one right the
variant allele cigarettes leaves five
very delicious cuisines bring a point
five point three point two point one
that's giving us some information about
the the fraction of cells with the
mutation so now we can think that our
data is not you know mutation or not in
each sample it's these these frequencies
so we could attempt to use these
frequencies to reconstruct our tree now
of course there's you know it's going to
be loss of information and going from
cells to to what we can measure so we
cannot think of maybe constructing a
tree on individual cells but maybe at
best constructing a tree on what we
might call clones which are groups of
cells that have all undergone the same
sort of clonal expansion so we can only
really detect mutations that are in some
you know modest frequency of cells so
really we're going to build these sort
of clone trees that describe the
relationship between clones yeah
the previous night so are you still
assuming the infinite sites model such
that you only see two orbitals in any
position or well I did that'll be on the
next slide so here I haven't sorted set
up the model but yes we will be making
that assumption here is just the data we
measured these frequencies right so we
want to build these trees so now yes
here's the problem given frequencies can
i find this clonal tree right and now
you can ask the question okay well what
phylogenetic model do you want to use
this is actually sort of a general
problem if I take a tree phylogenetic
tree if i give you the leaves of that
tree i can ask you to recover that tree
if I instead give you mixtures of the
leaves of that tree I can ask you to
recover that tree and now you could say
can I solve that problem under the
infinite sites model can I solve it
under box amad parsimony mano could I
solve an under a maximum likelihood
model you it's now a different two
different questions sort of a
phylogenetic mixture question if you
will so seems like you're pretty hard in
fact if I give you one measurement one
mixture you really can't kind of
reconstruct the tree seemingly at all
anything could happen unless you impose
some constraints so let's impose this
constraint the strongest constraint we
could impose the infinite sites
assumption now actually things do start
to happen because if a mutation happens
only once at a position then we actually
have a relationship between the
frequencies and the ancestry somehow a
simple relationship which is that if one
mutation is incest tral to another in
the tree which we don't know then the
frequency of that mutation the sample
has to be larger than the frequency of
the descent why because every cell that
gets this orange mutation had to have
the weight let me see the other right
right yeah sorry if the the gray
mutation here is ancestral every cell
with the orange mutation has the great
mutation okay so the frequency and the
cellular population of the great
mutation is larger than the orange one
this relates the two the two things so
now we have a constraint with one sample
you still can't do much because in fact
I could take this frequency data and
explain it as a linear tray just by
sorting the frequencies in order and
that would always explain what happened
so there's not really much interesting
to do without making another assumption
but now what about what happened what
what happened what about the case where
we measure not one mixture but now
multiple mixtures okay so now I have
sequenced multiple samples from my my
tumor so I've taken this phylogenetic
tree and I've given you multiple
mixtures of the leaves in certain
unknown proportions so could you from
this frequency data reconstruct the tree
and reconstruct the these mixing
frequencies and note again this is not
the tree relating the samples we're
trying to do more here so let me sort of
set up 11 problem here's our frequency
matrix here's the tree that we generated
this matrix could we recover this tree
from from the matrix if we make this
perfect phylogeny or infinite sites
assumption then we know that there's
this one-to-one correspondence between
trees and this special class of binary
matrices right the ones that meet these
conditions right the three Gammy's
condition for example if it's at all
rooted case now we have these matrices
and now for any tree it's described by
this one of these matrices we're going
to mix the leaves of the tree and we mix
those using some matrix that tells you
these proportions in which you mix so
every sample is a mixture of the leaves
or clones here then the number the
entries in this matrix have to some 22
less than 1 i've sort of yeah i've made
it less than 1 because there's also the
normal cell the one with no somatic
mutations the root so that's the missing
piece here so this first sample is
actually the previous slide here this
was a point point eight this was just
one leaf so we had you know eighty
percent of our samples it's one twenty
percent was the normal cells with no
mutations that's the rest of this so
that's the the other property and then
how do we describe matrix well it's just
a simple it's just linear algebra right
the frequencies are obtained by
multiplying you by B and then there's
this one half because under infinite
sites all mutations are heterozygous so
now all we need to do is invert this
problem giving a frequency matrix can
you factorize it
matrix like this you and a matrix be a
perfect phylogeny matrix know that both
of these matrices have structure right
so it's a special factorization problem
where you have these structure matrices
I'm not going to describe the algorithms
there have been different many different
ways to sort of attack this problem some
some are you know heuristic some solved
a problem exactly some solve it using
you know quadratic programming
techniques some do the sort of one
sample case and impose extra constraints
but the other thing I wanted to say is
the setup that I gave you has no errors
in the data like there were no errors
and it didn't deal with the fact that we
need to kind of cluster the mutations
right so as we discussed with detecting
mutations and building clones we need to
deal with clustering the mutation so
there are approaches that use dursley
process models but even further sort of
tree structure dursley process models to
simultaneously cluster variant allele
frequencies and build the tree according
to these constraints you'll hear about
these models further in the workshop and
extension is easy of these models to
dealing with with other aberrations okay
so i will then look at the aspect of
noisy data and if we go back to our
outline here so ben has focused very
much on the mixture aspect trying to
deke involve the different clones that
are present in one such sample and i
will focus now on on the fact that the
observations are noisy and that is the
case in particular for single-cell data
so in a way looking at single cells is
easier than looking at the mixtures but
on the other hand I will make this
aspect of noisy observations very
explicit the other reason I will focus
on single cells know is that we can do
single cell sequencing now and there's
more of these data accumulating and I
think in the near future there will be a
lot of these single cell sequencing data
be available so this is just the same
situation we have looked at
before let's say starting from this
ideal situation the clonal origin of the
tumors on the top and evolution now runs
from the top to the bottom so what we
would observe at the current time point
is is down here there's a mixture of
different clones coexisting in the tumor
and we would draw a sample a sample a
random sample from the tumor in the form
of a collection of individual cells and
each of these cells has a certain set of
mutations indicated by these by these
symbols inside the cell so the data
again the traffic data that might come
from such an experiment is again a
binary matrix and where the roles are
here labeled with the mutations and the
columns with the cells and the one here
simply indicates that this particular
mutation was present in this particular
cell and a zero would mean that this
mutation does not occur in this
particular cell so you're just recording
you're just detecting for each cell the
mutations that are present or not in the
cell so then what we would like to do
again is from these data to reconstruct
a tree and a phylogenetic tree again
would look like this the cells would
label the leaves of the tree and the
mutations would curl along the edges as
you trace down a path from the root of
the tree the unique path from the root
to any of the vertices of the cells in
the tree so what we think in a sense is
more convenient to do here is rather
than looking at a phylogenetic tree
looking at a mutation tree so in the
mutation tree the vertices the interior
vertices are labeled with the mutations
also there's one vertex for each
mutation and the samples of the cells
there are attached to this mutation tree
so for example these three samples here
attached to this mutation this sample
has been attached to this mutation and
so on and it's not very hard to see that
of course under the infinite sites
assumption that we continue to make here
and these two representations are
equivalent it's just a different way
essentially of
presenting the situation however this
one here turns out to be a little more
convenient when it comes to noisy
observations so let's look at noise so
here's another very simple tree a
smaller one with a root vertex here
mutation one mutation to a mutation
three only three mutations and the seven
or so samples are attached to the
different leaves in this particular
manner so the expected or the perfect
data that you would get from from a
sequencing experiment when this is the
the underlying truth would look like
this so here are the different samples
and these are their mutation profiles so
for sell one or sample one you would
have mutation one but not two not three
and so on and in reality the data that
you might obtain will have arrows so
instead of having a one here for example
you might have a zero so you were not
able to detect that mutation you didn't
call that mutation so that would be a
false negative and there can also be
false positives like here rather than is
zero you actually have one in your data
set so you called the mutation but it is
not really a mutation so false positive
so this is something that standard
phylogenetic methods again do not take
into account they always assume the data
is correct and perfect and and as I said
in the beginning for single cell data
it's very important to account for these
false positives and false negatives
because they are very frequent so I will
not go into great detail of the
likelihood but the first step here is to
simply write down what the probability
of this data matrix is given of course
the tree and then given two more sets of
parameters theta it just summarizes the
false positive and the false negative
rate and I will talk about Sigma at the
moment and then this model really just
says its independent over the
observations and it's independent over
the mutations that factorized over both
of these and this probability of not
writing down what this probability is
justice essentially binomial as the
probability of flipping from a 0 to a 1
or from a 1
zero with these false positive and false
negatives rates so that's that's as
simple as it gets the way we look at
this model now is that we do not really
care about the attachment of the sample
so much so in a way the focus shifts
from trying to estimate the dependencies
among the samples to estimating the
order among the mutations because in a
way I think this is what we would care
about more how did the mutations occur
rather than getting exactly right the
evolutionary relationship between all
the single cells in a way this is mainly
what we would care about and here are
two identical mutation trees but with
different attachments of the samples and
we wouldn't care so much whether we have
the situation on the left or on the
right-hand side but we do care whether
we get the order and the dependencies of
limitations correct is that a question
sorry yeah single cells how are you
handling issue of missing data in terms
of drop out or insufficient sequencing I
will I mean I will not go into great
detail but the short answer is that this
is a full probabilistic model so this is
hidden data in the probabilistic model
and we treated a certain data so you
have to do some sort of inference either
trying to estimate the hidden data or
integrating it out something like this
in fact the example I will show you in a
minute has a lot of missing data and I
hope to convince you that we get
something reasonable all of it good let
me try to do that ok so again the focus
is on the order of the mutations and in
the attachment of the samples becomes a
noise ins primita so you would like to
get rid of it and the most natural way
to do that is to integrate it out right
and if you try to do that it looks a bit
difficult so Sigma is the vector that
tells you for each sample where to
attach it to which mutation should be
attached so Sigma J is where to attach
where to attach
to which mutation to attach sample
number J so if you have to some no
overall these vectors Sigma that would
be hopeless to ever compute the
likelihood right all ready for moderate
numbers of mutations and samples that
will be hopeless but it turns out the
likelihood will factor over the
individual mutations so that's just a
product here over the samples and then
there is a some only over the possible
values for each Sigma J so you don't
need to consider this exponential number
of possibilities but but only in this
product over the samples so in a way the
whole focus now shifts to shift from the
samples to the mutations so you can
compute the likelihood efficiently and
then depending on what you do about the
prior distribution here you can also
compute the posterior probability and
that gives you a way of pursuing a
bayesian approach to sample from the
posterior probability in in this way we
essentially reduced the the complexity
so the tree size essentially no big is
the number of the number of mutations
rather than number of samples now
depending of course on your application
that can be an advantage or disadvantage
I think in the probably not so long a
time we will have a lot of cells and we
will probably be interested in the
dependencies of a smaller number of
mutation so I think it will at some
point be an advantage that the
complexity is essentially driven by the
number of mutations rather than by the
number of samples although in these very
first and early studies that we have
right now we don't have so many single
cells because it's still costly and so
on I think that will change quickly so I
want one more thing I would like to
point out is of course that you still
have to find the optimal tree topology
and there's no simple way of doing that
and one thing that that we're doing here
this vision approach is just a Markov
chain Monte Carlo approach that
samples from the street space so here's
this one example that I would like to
show you it's a rather old single cell
sequencing data set it's a very recent
technology that was one of the first
papers published 2012 single cell
sequencing data of a myeloproliferative
neoplasms and the authors they are
sequenced 58 cancer cells 58 cells from
that from the tumor and they somehow
selected 18 mutations here that has been
done by the authors are not going into
this and this data said had in fact this
amazing fraction of forty five percent
missing data so the technology has
gotten much better the data that
generated today has much less missing
data still has quite quite quite a
fraction of missing data in addition the
false positive rate for this data set
was estimated also by the authors and
I'm not going into it to be moderate
right six times ten to the minus five
whereas the false negative rate was
again very high it was 0 point for three
for this particular data set so again
and you you cannot treat these data with
a standard phylogeny approach where you
just assume the data is complete and
correct that we are far from from that
situation this is the data matrix again
the samples are the columns and the
mutations are the rows and all the brown
spots here are the missing data so there
is really a large fraction of missing
data yes progeny so in fact perfect
phylogeny can easily handle missing date
is in the same time puppy in the same
time bomb okay since the Alpha is so
small and maybe the only problem is the
better and maybe it's worthwhile to
compare whatever you do
using you know mud alcove chain monte
carlo to use it for production yeah
absolutely that's a good point I mean we
didn't compare it at this point I mean
one other aspect is of course if you do
a probabilistic treatment you have a
notion of uncertainty we have the whole
posterior but that's another aspect yeah
that's a good point ok so then doing
this I will never let show you're only
11 optimal tree that we found and it
looks indeed like this so the vertices
are labeled with the jeans so the
mutation occurred in each of these jeans
and as you see the structure of the tree
is is fairly linear so almost a single
linear path except for this this one
branching point down here so this model
is completely consistent with this
clonal evolutionary theory where these
mutations accumulate in individual
selective sweeps each of which is driven
by one such mutation or maybe by a
subset of those and we can also look at
the optimal attachment of the samples
the samples of the gray nodes here and
I'm only show and I'm connecting it to
several vertices here when the optimal
assignment was not unique right so for
example this sample 19 here all the
optimal assignments are to all of these
mutations on the top here and so on and
as you see for most of the cells the the
optimism is not unique and this reflects
of course the uncertainty that's due to
this large amount of missing data and
the high rates especially or false
negatives you can also see that most of
the cells are attached to the bottom of
the tree here as you would expect
probably because all of these are
mutations that have occurred in the past
and and most of the cells that we are
observing are down here they do have all
of these mutations on the top plus some
of the newer ones that are generated
more recently
good so so much for the phylogeny part
and unless you have questions here I
will end this part with making a small
comment on the more complex aberrations
yes the authors of the original study do
any collapsing or trade organizations
together or is this a result of
clustering but these are individual
integer these are individual notations
and they are just your lovely presented
to go for flowers ourselves so they
won't know because it looks like a
miracle that you live don't have any
poop relaxing together this what you
mean by collapsing you can distinguish
me that you always have some sample that
can distinguish between any two
consecutive laws in this very own change
yeah almost I mean like the first three
for example okay there's this maybe
these two I cannot okay I didn't check
this in detail but I'm not sure it's
it's true what you're saying and of
course it depends i'm just showing you
again the optimal assignment here i mean
what we are really interested is just
the tree on the left hand side right the
three
really though I mean maybe i should say
in general it in we also look at other
data sets i will not show them today in
general that does frequently occur that
we kept that there is a group of
mutations that occurred that we cannot
distinguish because we have no sample
here right in general that is clearly a
future and that's what you would expect
from from very ancestral mutations that
they're just no cells left or not many
at least that would be able to
distinguish absolutely possibly related
that what's represented by the multiple
arcs so like from the fourth purple
thing dmx l12 s6 has like six arcs
connecting them yes so again what I'm
showing here is the optimal assignment
of samples to the mutations and and
often that assignment is not unique so
several assignments have have the same
optimal probability optimal likelihood
and then I'm that figure I'm showing all
of them
this is like s19 on the top right is
connected to six of the of the genes yes
but then s 6 on the bottom right has
like six connections one of the genes
its bit of a lot of war throw up you
you're close to there which one s at six
right yes it's like there's multiple
connections like not that one the lower
yes I think it's just a custom the
others mixing up okay and the question
is why that is yeah the question is is
it is again that the assignment is not
unique I mean really what we're doing is
we're integrating this out and we're
only looking at the tree on the left
hand side but I'm showing you this
figure to give you a feeling for the
uncertainty that one has in assigning
these samples and in other words i'm
doing this to give you additional reason
to integrate this out it is in a way
noise ins prom it would not be possible
in a meaningful way to decide for one of
these assignments that's the whole point
where is the structure of the mutation
tree on the left hand side it means the
same on the right hand side but the
structure only among the red vertices
that one is is robust and is meaningful
so maybe the following question will be
trivially true but answerable but the
possible assignments are they all going
to form a connected component
I don't think so i don't know and i
haven't thought about it that's of
course that's the anyway the most
obvious reason so but I'm not sure that
this is that one can prove it yeah
but have you gone back and see what now
but two samples are linked to the same
mutation at a HP mutated at the same
position or completely different
position different positions of it they
will I mean of course in a way that's
all encoded in the probabilistic model
in the likelihood right but they will
they will tend I mean the ideas of
course so I mean basically it's like
this if you okay let's maybe go to the
ideal setting here so the way let's say
this sample six down here is defined is
your trace of the path from the root to
that sample and all the mutations you
pick up on that path so in other words
sample six would have executive mutation
to and mutation free
okay I mean that's a matter of how you
do how you define these what you can
what do you mean by imitation here right
how you encode the binary matrix and you
can say well I want to look at the very
specific single nucleotide variant for
example or you can say okay whenever the
same gene is mutated in a similar way
then I summarize that as the same
mutation just discrete events here
I mean this is only in this in this
specific application where the where the
mutations here have been summarized per
gene and therefore the notes here are
labeled with jeans but you could apply
to the same manner to I don't know snv's
of one gene for example or whatever
right or other genetic events that you
measure why didn't march into how like
same three percent structure sing order
this is for one this is for one tumor
for one patient only we're making here
inference from one tumor and I'm only
saying this is most likely according to
our model what has happened in this one
tumor or in the sample we got from the
tomb and then
exactly what but let's say it's in a way
more abstract yeah I mean in a way it's
more abstract because we're just saying
there are these mutational events and a
principle that could also be a certain
rearrangement and you just record is it
present or not in any of these cells so
this is not not linked to any specific
type of mutation but on the other hand
that doesn't account for the
dependencies of these mutations they are
not independent in a real tumor right in
that in that's I mean the whole starting
point of a binary matrix is of course
there is simplifying okay more questions
at this point yes in the next graph yes
so for example s9 has all the all the
mutations ss9 here no s9 has all of
these mutation spoon
core yeah did you point to no good you
have some of the Forgotten s19 you have
all the Ark's but for s 19 you're not
sure if some of the marker that's the
fact that there's multiple ox2 s19
reflects my uncertainty to assign s19 to
one of the dots i realized there should
remove this figure from my next
presentation I thought it was an I
squared okay let me show you a question
no okay let me move on and finish this
part by again briefly mentioning that
things are more complex that you have
already alluded to that you are what
about deletions and so on and yes life
is more complicated and there are a few
early attempts to get at the let's say
rearrangement tumor follow j'ni Chris
greenman for example we'll talk about
this at the workshop here so in reality
more complex things can happen as we
discussed earlier today so for example
here's an example where you start with a
normal genome and then you have complex
genetic events here's an inverted
duplication a breakage fusion bridge
cycle and the chromosomal duplication
and so on many other things can happen
so the end result in general is not
easily to summarize in a simple binary
matrix and snv's alone again we'll
probably not do the trick so there are
efforts in trying to reconstruct the
rearrangement to Buffalo j'ni but it
turns out to be much more complicated
and there's no simple problem here to
formulate okay with that I would then
like 20 it's already fairly late what am
I going to do now I give it back to bed
now so a plan was in the second part to
talk a bit about population dynamics and
where's my chair here it's you right
genk what what are you saying now
let's let's perhaps of a little separate
for finance and if you'd like to conquer
you tomorrow okay we are continuing to
millenium anyways in a session so i give
the five minute version of this okay so
the point is that all these phylogenetic
methods they of course care about the
tree the genealogies so they care about
estimating the dependencies among the
samples or maybe among the mutations but
they have no notion of the dynamics of
this process there is no mutation rate
in the first place in particular there's
no population size the population size
plays a big role and population genetics
models address this aspect and I had put
together a few very simple examples to
illustrate that point and the first one
is the inactivation as or the activation
of oncogenes no oncogenes are simply
those jeans let's say they are driver
genes but there are those driver genes
that can be activated by single event
that's either a point mutation on one of
the chromosomes or a gene amplification
or chromosomal fusion so that's the way
to activate an oncogene and the dynamics
of this process are very simple because
you have this one event so the
probability that such a mutant with a
activated oncogene has been fixed in the
population of tumor cells by time T
simply follows exponential distribution
source 1 minus e to the minus and then
the rate here is nu Rho T where n is the
population size so here it matters how
large the tumor is how many cells there
are use the mutation rate and Rho is the
fixation probability so the probability
that once that mutation has been
generated it will actually reach
fixation in the population so the way to
think of this is that n times you
sometimes called the total mutation rate
that's the total chance of generality of
generating the mutation in the
population and now it's intuitively
clear that the population size plays a
big role
here in a larger tumor you have a higher
chance of generating that mutation as
compared to a smaller tube and row again
if the probability that it will
eventually reach fixation that can be
computed under simple population
genetics model more on process and so on
for example so this very simple model
already shows you that large
compartments accelerate the accumulation
of advantageous mutations and small
compartments where there's a small
number of cells susceptible to such
mutation will slow it down and in fact
most tissues with a high cell turnover
where cancer can occur and does occur
eventually are organized in many small
such compartments and and and the
typical example of the Colonia crypts in
the colon so in a way you can argue that
these tissues are organized in a way to
prevent cancer as much as possible so
having a large number of cells organize
the small compartments is in a way a
good protection against the activation
of of an oncogene now the other class of
driver genes are the tumor suppressor
genes and in a way these are genes that
protect you from cancer and they are
recessive so in order to inactivate them
you sort of need two events for example
two point mutations one on the one
chromosome and the other one on the
other chromosome or and actually that's
very common you have a single you have
one mutation on one of the chromosomes
and then you have a loss of
heterozygosity then you either lose the
second copy or you just lose the hetero
zygosity so you just end up with two
identical copies and therefore both of
these copies are affected so in other
words in order to inactivate a tumor
suppressor gene you have to affect both
copies of of the earlier now the
dynamics of this process turn all to be
more complicated and I'm not showing you
how this works but I'm giving you the
basic result here and the dynamics of
this process depends very much on
population size now for small population
sizes on the left here the typical
scenario looks like this you start with
cells that have none of these events and
then here comes up sub profanation that
has the first hit but it goes extinct
again this one again has a goes extinct
this one eventually reaches fixation and
then after it has reached fixation the
second event occurs here so here the
tumor suppressor gene is inactivated so
in other words this is a two-hit
scenario you first need the first
mutation to reach fixation and then
across the second one now for
intermediate population sizes it turns
out that again you have the first
mutation coming out but typically the
second mutation occurs while the first
one is still fluctuating and before it
has reached fixation in the population
these were people sometimes called
stochastic tunneling so you don't need
to wait for the first month of each
fixation but the second one typically
occurs much before that so in terms of
the rate limiting steps that's a one-hit
process and finally in very large
population sizes mathematically it looks
like two hits but they are not rate
limiting so in a way here its immediate
right you immediately grow with your
type 1 mutant and the second one occurs
immediately so it goes very fast in
other words in large population size ok
the the third part I wanted to address
was the progression of tumors and i will
show you only one slide here and maybe
this one this is a simulation from a
model where you start with something
like a million cells here and there is a
certain evolutionary process that just
accounts for mutations accumulating in
the tumor and the different curves here
correspond to different clones defined
by the number of mutations so we start
with no mutation here then comes here
the clone that has one driver mutation
and why this clone is growing you have
for the first cells with two mutations
and how do you get ourselves to
mutations well the second mutation
occurs on the growing clone with one
mutation and you see that's initially a
very stochastic process they go extinct
they come back and so on and then
only when they reach a certain size they
grow almost deterministically and over
all these mutations come almost on the
clock like fashion right the selective
sweeps go through the population and
this manner of mutations are accumulated
ok I will skip a bit here and just make
one more comment in the end that you can
also use these types of models to
predict the effect of treatment mona
vers versus combination treatment has
been mentioned at some point before he
has a such a study using these types of
models comparing monotherapy to dual
therapies or treatment with two
compounds and the total tumor load is
shown here in this greenish color and
the subpopulation of resistance cells
are shown in red and oh and as you see
in that in the top row depending on the
parameters of the model you have a much
harder time reducing the load of the
tumor and also preventing the
development of drug resistance which
eventually will lead to recurrence of
the tomb ok with that I would like to
end this part and and on this very last
slide just compiled a few things that
might be interesting or even special
about cancer development in cancer
revolution because I know there's a
number of people here interested in this
process from an evolutionary biology
point of view I think these tumors are
very interesting evolutionary systems
one aspect we emphasized a lot in the
first session today was that cancer
genomes Harbor very complex operations
the second one that in the in the
context of networks I think became very
apparent as cancers the evolution of
defection because there's many ways of
breaking certain signaling pathways for
example and that's one reason why there
is many selectively advantages many
secretary advantageous mutations
available for cancer to evolve so
there's many drivers basically because
there's many ways to interfere with the
signaling pathways that usually control
the cells and once you interfere with
them these cells go wild and they don't
behave from the
tissue properly anymore they replicate
more than the shirt and so on tumors are
specific population structures of course
in a way that that's true for almost any
evolutionary system but also let's say
in tumors at least or especially in
solid tumors that plays a big role and
the fate of mutations depends a lot on
the structure I didn't have time to go
into it but the fixation probability and
the fixation time of a mutant depends a
lot not only on the usual parameters
like population size mutation rate and
so on selective advantage but also on
the structure of the population and
finally and this points to what I will
be talking about tomorrow morning one
special aspect of this evolutionary
process is that if you collect data from
different tumors of the same type as we
are doing of course at a large scale
then you have iid data from these tumors
so there is an evolutionary process that
is repeated independently in different
individuals of course not exactly the
same but it's a fairly similar process
and that's again something very unusual
for an evolutionary process because most
of the evolutionary processes we only
observe the end result of it's happening
once right and you hardly ever have a
chance to repeat this stochastic process
and with tumors you have this iid data
so I think this is a big difference and
this makes gives us a lot of
opportunities to modeling this
evolutionary process to look for
parallel and even reproducible
evolutionary processes so how much of
this process is actually producible if
it occurs in different patients and the
question then at the end of the day how
much of this evolutionary process can we
actually predict so far largely very
much takes the point of view into the
past trying to reconstruct the past
history but the data that we have a
thing can do much more and we can ask
how much of this evolution process can
we predict and at the end of the day use
that to make to make predictions that
hopefully are clinically important
relevant thank you and I apologize for
going over time
oh very quick question maybe but
yes so just a red to the last point here
actually how do we know the jurors are
from the same type affair yeah that's a
good question I mean of course the way
we do it now is the tumor types are it
is mainly categorized by histology right
and so that's probably what I mean at
this point but I think your your point
is very well taken is that
classification really the right one or
the best one so it's so exactly comes
back to the sub typing problem that we
mentioned earlier based on the molecular
profiles but but even then that's I mean
every tumor will be different that's
clear right I mean of course you can say
no this doesn't make sense because every
tumor is different and that's probably a
fair perspective but the hope is that
some are similar enough such that you
can learn common features of those
we're talking about all this was talking
about global expansion that looks like a
tree I've seen some papers recently
biological papers that suggests that
there can be some reticulate behavior
and the expansion of the cells these two
tumor cells in different organs somehow
communicate and affect each other is
that I don't know much about it I don't
think there's a lot established I mean
it's of course no recombination here per
se and other I don't know lateral gene
transfer and so on I'm not really aware
of it i I don't know there's certainly
very very little and that would of
course complicate things massively again
yeah I don't know I think at this point
we have no strong evidence for that
the woman I made science and nature's it
must have been one of those and I can't
say specific there are observations
suggest